lucas bonsoir alors gérald darmanin est
actuellement sur place où il s'est
exprimé tout à l'heure oui olivier
gérald darmanin étaient sur place
il est reparti il ya un peu plus d'une
heure maintenant ce qu'on peut dire sur
cette visite c'est que l été marquée par
la présence de certains curieux qui
était à l'extérieur de ce bâtiment ce
bâtiment que vous voyez derrière moi où
a eu lieu le crime et ces personnes et
biens voulait demander des comptes à
gérald darmanin car le profil de ce
meurtrier présumé de ce criminel présumé
interpelle je vous propose d'écouter une
des personnes avec qui j'ai pu discuter
au cours de cette journée parce que je
pense que c'est malheureusement encore
une énième fois qu'on retrouve ce même
schéma
demain ce sera où ça sera quand on sait
pas on a déjà eu le cas sur d'autres
villes
ce genre d'assassinât eux-mêmes dans les
églises donc je pense aujourd'hui qu'il
a encore voilà une attitude laxiste avec
un certain nombre de phénomènes
il devrait avoir un peu plus de
concertation et un peu plus de célérité
on va dire vous l'avez dit cette affaire
a pris une tournure nettement plus
politique quand il a été rendu public
quand il a été révélé que sept personnes
avaient été impliqués et bien dans l'
incendie de la cathédrale de nantes en
juillet 2020 il avait avoué avoir allumé
plusieurs incendies la présidente
notamment du rassemblement national
s'était étonné que cette personne qui
faisait déjà l'objet d'un arrêté
d'expulsion avant ses aveux bien n'est
pas été expulsé ce à quoi gérald
darmanin lui avait répondu dans la
journée que cette personne ne pouvait
pas être expulsé tout simplement parce
qu'elle était encore sous contrôle
judiciaire lorsqu'il est lorsqu'il a
parlé aujourd'hui devant la presse il a
fustigé la démagogie de certains de ses
opposants je vous propose de l'écouter
tout de suite certains ont cédé à la
tentation de la polémique la tentation
de la démagogie au moment où
l'esprit le corps de ce prêtre n'était
pas encore en paix le contact que j'ai
eu l'honneur avec l'église de france
avec les prêtres qui n'ont bien connu et
qui ont accueilli cette personne ici
n'était pas de ces mêmes esprits
effectivement je m'étonne plus
malheureusement
mais je regrette ces polémiques qui sont
totalement infondées qui nous deux buts
dans ce corps d'élite et que de fait
relève de la démagogie
je vais m'arrêter là par respect envers
la famille reste à voir la congrégation
religieuse et monsieur au coeur de la
république a eu l'occasion de s'exprimer
on imagine aura l'occasion dans les
jours qui viennent sont inquiètes mais
la polémique continue d'enfler puisque
pour les détracteurs de ce gouvernement
et bien il s'agit de la défaillance de
trop des autorités alors même qu'il est
demandé à la population générale de
faire un effort puisque aujourd'hui
et bien c'est le jour de l'application
de la loi qui étend lusage du pass
sanitaires quoi qu'il en soit ici et
bien une enquête a été ouverte une
enquête pour homicide volontaire a
annoncé le procureur le vice procureur
de la république de la roche sur yon qui
nous a aussi a décrit est bien un
personnage qui sortait d'un séjour en
hôpital psychiatrique d'un mois il était
sorti le 29 juillet si beaucoup lucas
pour toutes ces précisions lucas léger
en direct de saint laurent sur sèvre